we are not alone in our bodies instead
we are colonized by many microorganisms
these includes bacteria fungi and
viruses collectively we referred to this
as our microbiome so hello and welcome
to the Shiki science show where in this
video we're going to look at how eating
alters your gut microbiome so this video
will cover what actually is the
microbiome what the microbiome is doing
with our foods and then we'll look at
some of the daily oscillations in the
microbiome and the impacts of diets and
feeding patterns on this oscillation
will then look at whether or not we can
use microbiome and tracking the patterns
in the oscillation as a biomarker and
predictive tool so you assess the risk
of developing different diseases such as
type 2 diabetes and then we'll look at
current methods in which if you wanted
to you could actually get your
microbiome assessed and then finally
I'll give my own future opinions and
outlook on where this field is going so
let's start with what is the microbiome
so as I said us humans are colonized by
trillions of microorganisms and this is
effectively the aggregate of all the
different microbiota that resides on or
within different human tissues and bio
fluids such as the skin the lungs our
oral cavity and with respect to this
video our gods and say that is referred
to as our guts microbiome so while some
of these microorganisms are beneficial
others are pathogenic and so the
important thing to take from this is
that these microbes are not just
passengers but then our bodies but they
actually play an active role within our
bodies for example studies have shown
that these microorganisms have a key
role in metabolism immunity and neural
development just to name a few and
that's just from our understanding so
far and this is due to the actions that
these microorganisms are playing with in
the body for example they can produce
their own metabolites and they also help
to digest different metabolites while
our cells cannot digest themselves so
maybe it isn't surprising that there's
also evidence showing that there are
links between the microbiome
and different diseases and this includes
the seasons such as outside mr. sees
autism depression obesity cancer
autoimmune diseases such as multiple
sclerosis and as will mention later
type-2 diabetes treatments for these
different diseases therefore may come
from targeting these different
microorganisms that are used the drugs
or by the use of card microbiome
transplants say where you transfer some
microbiota so whilst the latter is a bit
more advanced by understanding the
biochemistry behind these different
micro microorganisms this helps us
understand disease development and
treatments but a much simpler treatment
may just be three modifying diets as
there are now studies showing that diets
alters the composition of the microbiome
and that's the really important thing to
understand is that our microbiome is not
static and it varies depending on your
age your geographical location your sex
and as I mentioned your diets and not
only does it change on these larger
timescales but there are also daily
fluctuations within the gut microbiome
composition as well as we'll talk about
in this video so what is the microbiome
doing with our foods so as I mentioned
the microbiome can impact human
physiology by participating in digestion
the absorption of nutrients and shaping
our immune response as well as
synthesizing their own bioactive
compounds and so some of these compounds
are synthesized through dietary fiber
and generate these short chain fatty
acids these short chain fatty acids can
then be absorbed by the host moreover
these microbes have a role in
synthesizing vitamin B and vitamin K as
well as metabolizing other compounds
such as bile acids and so the
relationship we have with our gut
microbiome can be described as a
mutualistic relationship because we kind
of depend on each other to survive so
how does the composition of our diets
alter the composition of the gut
microbiome well one first good
introductory example can be seen by the
examining how the gut microbiome can
change during age and say if we look at
this graph here we can see that the
diversity of these
different microbial species fluctuates
throughout age and so initially we get
this boost and increased diversity
during infancy and that mainly comes
from the change in the diets when you
begin to eat solid foods and so that
kind of reaches a kind of Plateau
through adulthood and eventually you
send to see a decline in diversity
partly due to reflection or reduced free
diversity in old age but the level
that's reached during adulthood is free
hugely impacted by diets and so a really
interesting study looks at how the
amount of prebiotic fiber in a diets
influences the composition of the
microbiome and so one particular species
by feeli bacteria is very important in
protecting the leakiness of the clonic
mucus layer which effectively is a layer
that protects the host cells from the
microbiome and interestingly in the
study they found that mice on a
western-style diet so that would be a
diet high in saturated fats and simple
carbohydrates but depleted of dietary
fiber had a reduction in this particular
species of bacteria and an increased
permeability of this membrane mucus
layer and so the consequence that this
has is it puts the hotels at risk of
infection by different pathogenic
microorganisms such as Clostridium
difficile that can cause disease in
humans so what they did in this study is
the mice that were on the western-style
diet they transplanted microbiota from
normally fed mice and this helped to
prevent the deterioration of this mucous
layer so studies like this really
enforced the importance of the
composition of the microbiome but it's
not just the composition that's
important
there are also observable daily
oscillations of the composition of the
microbiome throughout the daily cycle
and these can become defective in
disease
let me explain so one of the best papers
to begin discussing is the cell
metabolism paper diet and feeding
pattern affect the
dynamics of the gut microbiome which
came out of such an pandas lab and so I
consider this a somewhat landmark paper
in terms of understanding these diurnal
oscillations in the microbiome
composition and so the results from the
study can be best described to free
their graphical abstracts so what we can
see is that in normally fed's
mice they have this daily cyclic ooh
fluctuations in the composition of the
microbiome and what they saw was that
diet induced obesity within these mice
dampened the daily feeding fasting
rhythms and it diminished many of these
cyclic cool fluctuations and this
resulted in thir mice becoming obese
however when they use time restricted
feeding in which the feeding was just
restricted to the nocturnal phase which
is when the mice would normally be
active it actually to some extent
restored these cyclic or fluctuations
and prevented these mice from becoming
obese so I like the study because it
kind of builds upon what I mentioned in
my last video about the importance of
intermittent fasting and how when you
eat is actually important to consider
and it kind of suggests that some of
that beneficial impacts of intermittent
fasting may be mediated through
promoting the fluctuations of the
microbiome composition so yes you're at
the moment these are more correlations
as opposed to causation but yeah this
paper was very interesting but it is not
the only one because a paper came out
roughly a year later Effects of diurnal
variation of gut microbes and high fat
feeding on host circadian clock function
and metabolism pretty much backed up the
data from the first paper however this
study goes a bit further by showing that
the manipulation and modification of the
microbiome alters the metabolites that
are produced by these microorganisms and
this has the effects of also altering
the circadian rhythm that goes on in the
surrounding neighboring cells in the gut
and how that can have an impact on the
physiology of the mouse in this case so
what they saw was in low or high fat
feeding there were differences in the
short chain fatty acid
that were produced by the microorganisms
and these directly modulated the
circadian clock gene expression within
the liver cells and so this shows how
the microbiome and their derived
metabolites can actually regulate or
modify the central circadian rhythm and
whose metabolic function and how that
can results in different physiology is
whether or not the mice is lean or obese
and their conclusion is that this
potentially comes from a shift in a
metabolic state from a high to a low
metabolic states which can help to
explain why we see these differences but
these studies so far they've been done
on mice what about humans well a study
has shown that there are also diurnal
variations in the microbiome composition
in humans and similarly these cyclic
variations can be dampened by different
diseases for example in this study they
showed that patients with type 2
diabetes had a reduced oscillation in
some microbial species so the results
from this study is best summarized and
these graphs here so each individual in
this huge cohort that they had gave them
a stool sample and also the time of day
in which that stool sample was retrieved
nice silk welts and their microbiome was
assessed and because he has such a large
cohort you inevitably get different time
points of these different stool samples
but you have the microbiome assessed and
then they could split up so based on
whether or not the individual had type 2
diabetes or not so in this case the
results for non type 2 diabetes are
given in blue and the patients with type
2 diabetes are shown in red and so you
can see a clear difference between the
very nice awesome oscillations in the
blue curves whereas the red samples is
very like jagged and zigzag that doesn't
really seem to be a clear pattern or
these diurnal fluctuations that are
expected and so effectively what the
study shows is that if you can assess
the fluctuation in the microbiome
composition of the patients it could
potentially be used as
a diagnostic tool of a risk factor of
that patient developing type 2 diabetes
because they also had a cohort that they
referred to as pre-diabetic and you can
see it kind of fools in between the Reds
and the blue graphs so this is a great
tool but I guess one problem is you
would have to somehow assess these
diurnal variations and if you're doing
that purely by a stool sample it might
take you quite a long time to get enough
data to make that assessments but
nonetheless it was an interesting study
that kind of reinforces the MAL studies
that we also do see daily fluctuations
and I've got microbiome and that does
seem to have an impact whether or not
it's a causation of the disease or it's
an outcome of the disease that isn't too
clear but it shows that it could be a
reliable biomarker so kind of leading on
from this
how can you assess your own microbiome
well it turns out there are certain
companies that are offering to examine
your stool sample and give you their
analysis of your microbiome
for example there's one company called
Fayum that claims it's the only company
currently available to identify and
quantify the gut microbiota to salmon
what these living organisms are
producing and present personalized diet
and nutrition advice so this is an
example of one of the kind of readouts
you would get from one of these results
and they get these results by looking at
the RNA the transcriptome that's present
in the stool sample and then they use
machine learning to kind of come up with
that outcome as I'm a bit dubious about
these kind of companies at the moment
partly because the nature of machine
learning is that it needs data to train
on and pull improve over time and
secondly because what I just said this
is a stool sample taken from just one
time points and as you hopefully have
learned from this video so far we know
that the microbiome composition
fluctuates throughout the day
and so depending on when that sample was
collected you might end up with a
completely different personalized sides
and nutritional facts so yeah I'm a bit
on the fence about these companies at
the moment but it's kind of interesting
it shows that there's definitely some
entry
in understanding the microbiome father
and actually considering it as being
quite important so what is my outlook
for the future of this field then my
opinion is that these studies have kind
of given the opportunity for unique and
targeted strategies to try and treat a
variety of different diseases such as
type 2 diabetes or diet induced obesity
and this could range from manipulating
the gut microbe composition which could
at some point come from transplants of
the microbiota or I think is more likely
to come before that is actually using
drugs to targets some of their host
pathways of the gut microbes to restore
metabolic balance and to alter the
metabolic function of the microorganisms
and companies or add excess that are
trying to do this for example one
company I know of is pure tech health
and they are developing in their
pipeline a variety of different
treatments to do just this and not just
targets the microbes but also maybe to
mimic what the microorganisms are doing
for example they ask the question what
if we could treat immune and infectious
disease by mimicking the ways in which
the gut microbiota maintains a healthy
immune system in humans so that's super
cool and super interesting but before
these drugs and transplants potentially
come to fruition there's something
simpler that could be used which is
simply modification of the diodes and
already there seems to be at least in
like popular culture or just happens to
feed the magazines and articles that I
end up reading definitely a focus on
trying to eat foods that are good for
your microbiome and for example I've
seen a recent craze about the
consumption of kefir which is a
fermented milk product that contains
probiotic bacteria and obviously the
content of the bacteria will vary
depending on the source of the cafe you
have but some of them contain by feed a
bacterium which is the bacteria that I
mentioned in the study that promoted the
mucus layer which prevented the thinning
of the
so who knows I think yeah as more
research comes out there'll be more
interest in understanding the microbiome
further and I the honestly think is a
little bit underrated at the moment I
think definitely has the bigger impact
then we've realized and yeah just to
remember we are not alone in our bodies
so hopefully you've learned something
and as always thanks for listening